양자 정보와 계산 이해하기에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Wattrus이고요, IBM Quantum의 교육
기술 총괄 디렉터예요. 이번이 이 시리즈의 11번째 강의이고, 세 번째 단원의 세 번째 강의인데요,
세 번째 단원은 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 대한 내용이에요. 이번 강의는 측정에 관한 거예요. 측정은 양자와 고전
정보 사이의 인터페이스 역할을 해요. 시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 때 측정이 수행되면,
고전적인 정보가 추출되면서 그 양자 상태에 대한 무언가가 드러나게 되고, 보통 그 상태가 변하거나
과정 중에 파괴되어요. 이 시리즈의 첫 번째 단원에서 다뤘던 양자 정보의 간략한 공식화에서는 보통
사영 측정에 집중했어요. 가장 단순한 유형의 측정인
표준 기저 측정도 포함해서요. 하지만 측정의 개념을 일반화하는 것도 가능한데요,
그게 꽤 유용한 일이에요. 이번 강의에서는 측정을 완전히 일반적인 관점에서 다룰 거예요.
수학적으로 어떻게 표현되는지, 그리고 양자 정보의 일반적인 공식화에 어떻게 들어맞는지도요.
강의 마지막 부분에서는 측정과 연결된 몇 가지 핵심 개념도 살펴볼 거예요. 바로 양자 상태
판별과 양자 상태 단층 촬영이에요. 자, 시작해볼게요. 강의 개요를 먼저 보면요.
늘 그렇듯이 기본부터 시작할 거예요. 측정을 수학적으로 표현하는 두 가지 다르지만
동등한 방법을 포함해서요. 특히 측정을 행렬들의 모음으로 표현할 수 있고,
채널로도 표현할 수 있는데, 이전 강의에서 살짝 언급했었죠. 부분 측정도 다룰 거예요.
다시 말해 더 큰 복합 시스템의 일부에만 수행되는 측정이요.
그 다음에는 Neymark 정리로 넘어갈 거예요. 이건 측정에 관한 근본적인 사실인데요, 기본적으로
일반적인 측정은 항상 Stein spring 표현과 비슷한 방식으로 간단하게 구현할 수 있다는 내용이에요.
요약하면, 일반적인 측정은 항상 먼저 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템을 도입한 다음,
유니터리 연산을 수행하고, 마지막으로 작업 공간 시스템에 표준 기저
측정을 수행하는 방식으로 구현할 수 있어요. 이건 증명하기도 꽤 쉬운데, 어떻게 진행되는지 살펴볼 거예요. 또
이게 이른바 비파괴적 측정과 어떻게 연결되는지도 볼 거예요. 마지막으로 강의 마지막 부분에서는
양자 상태 판별과 양자 상태 단층 촬영에 대해 다룰 거예요. 측정의 수학적
표현부터 시작할게요. 측정은 양자와
고전 정보 사이의 인터페이스를 제공해요. 시스템이 어떤 양자 상태에 있을 때 측정이 수행되면, 고전적인 정보가
그 양자 상태로부터 추출돼요. 게다가 양자 상태는 보통 바뀌거나 경우에 따라서는
완전히 파괴되기도 해요. 처음에는 이른바 파괴적 측정에 집중할 거예요. 여기서는
양자 상태가 들어가고 고전적인 정보만 나오는데, 측정된 시스템의
측정 후 양자 상태에 대한 명세가 없어요. 직관적으로 말하면, 파괴적 측정은
측정된 시스템을 파괴한다고 상상할 수 있어요. 그래서 측정 이후의 상태가
명시되지 않는 거예요. 이게 물리적 장치가 실제로 파괴된다는 뜻은 아니에요. 그냥 수학적인
표현일 뿐이고, 이게 꽤 유용한 표현이에요. 왜냐하면 복잡한 것들을 단순하게 유지하고 핵심적인
수학적 측면에 집중할 수 있게 해주거든요. 파괴적 측정을 표현하는 두 가지 동등한 방법이 있는데,
강의 개요에서 언급했었죠. 파괴적 측정을 표현하는 한 가지 방법은
행렬들의 모음인데요, 특히 각각의 가능한 측정 결과에 대해 하나의 행렬이 있어요.
파괴적 측정을 표현하는 두 번째 방법은 채널인데요, 여기서
입력은 측정되는 시스템의 상태이고, 출력은 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이에요. 이걸
가능한 고전적인 측정 결과들에 대한 확률 분포의 표현으로 해석할 수 있어요.
두 가지 표현은 동등해요. 이게 꽤 유용한데, 주어진 상황에서 더 편리한 표현을 선택할 수 있게 해주기 때문이에요.
비파괴적 측정에 대해서도 다룰 거예요. 여기서는 고전적인 측정 결과 외에도
측정된 시스템의 측정 후 양자 상태도
명시돼요. 비파괴적 측정은 중요하고 자주 등장하지만, 어떤 의미에서는
파괴적 측정만큼 근본적이지는 않아요. 수학적인 관점에서는, 특히 결국
비파괴적 측정은 항상 채널과 파괴적 측정의 합성으로 표현될 수 있어요.
어떻게 그렇게 되는지는 강의 후반부에서 살펴볼게요. 이제 측정, 즉 파괴적
측정이 행렬들의 모음으로 어떻게 표현되는지 살펴볼게요. 이 논의 전반에 걸쳐 X는 측정되는 시스템이라고 할 거예요.
간단하게 하기 위해 몇 가지 가정을 할 거예요. 먼저, X의
고전적인 상태 집합이 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수로 구성된다고 가정할게요. 그리고 측정의 가능한
결과들은 어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해 0부터 M-1까지의 정수예요. 마찬가지로요.
n과 M 사이에 어떤 관계가 있을 필요는 없어요. 둘 다 임의의 양의 정수이고, 물론 이
집합들을 임의의 고전적인 상태 집합으로 대체할 수도 있어요. 먼저 사영
측정이 어떻게 작동하는지 복습해볼게요. 이 시리즈의 세 번째 강의에서 처음 다뤘었죠. 측정 결과가
0부터 n-1까지의 정수라고 가정하면, 사영 측정은 사영들의 모음으로 표현돼요.
Pi 0부터 Pi M-1까지인데, 이들의 합이 항등 행렬이 돼요. 이 행렬들은 모두 X의 고전적인 상태에 대응하는 행과
열을 가져요. 다시 말해 이것들은 모두 n×n
행렬이에요. x가 양자 상태 벡터 s로 표현되는 양자 상태에 있다면, 각각의 가능한 측정
결과 a는 Pi a를 벡터 s에 곱한 것의 유클리드 노름의 제곱과 같은 확률로 나타나요.
어떤 벡터의 유클리드 노름의 제곱은 그 벡터와 자기 자신의 내적과 같아요.
그래서 화면에 표시된 식을 얻게 되고, Pi a가 사영이라는 사실을 이용하면
조금 더 단순화할 수 있어요. 자기 자신에 곱해도 아무 변화가 없거든요.
그리고 마지막으로 순환 성질을 이용해서 얻은 식을 약간 다른 방식으로 다시 쓸 수 있어요.
화면에 표시된 것처럼 다시 트레이스의 순환 성질을 이용해서요. 왜 이런 식으로 쓰고 싶은지 명확하지 않다면,
간단히 말하면 사영 측정이 밀도 행렬에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하고 싶기 때문이에요.
특히 선형성에 의해, X의 상태가 양자 상태 벡터 s가 아니라 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된다면,
결과 a가 나타날 확률은 사영 Pi a와 밀도 행렬 ρ의 곱의 트레이스로 주어져요.
이렇게 되어야 하는 이유는, 앞서 살펴본 것처럼 밀도 행렬을 항상 순수 상태들의 가중 평균으로 생각할 수 있기 때문이에요.
그리고 해당 확률들을 평균하면 이 식을 얻게 되는데, 트레이스가 선형 함수이기 때문이에요. 바로 이게 우리가
얻으려는 식이에요. 밀도
행렬에 집중하도록 조금 정리할 수 있어요. 이렇게 하는 주된 목적은
이미 배운 내용과의 기준점을 세우기 위한 거예요.
그리고 사영 측정의 이 표현이 사실 곧 살펴볼 더 일반적인 측정 표현의 특수한 경우임을 확인하기 위해서이기도 하고요.
그래서 이제 밀도 행렬에 대한 사영 측정이 작동하는 방식의 표현을
일반적인 측정에 대한 표현으로 바꿔볼게요. 그러면 둘의 관계를 이해할 수 있어요. 여기 있어요.
반드시 사영 측정일 필요는 없는 일반적인 측정은, 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치
행렬들의 모음 p0부터 PM-1까지로 표현돼요. 그리고 이 측정이 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태의 X에 대해 수행되면,
각각의 결과 a는 PA × ρ의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요.
요약하면, 바뀐 것은 이 행렬들에 대한 조건을 완화했다는 것뿐이에요. 특히 이 행렬들은
사영 행렬일 필요가 없고, 그냥 양의 반정치이기만 하면 돼요. 그에 따라 Pi 대신 p라는 문자를 사용했는데,
Pi는 사영에 관용적으로 쓰이는 이름이지만, 저는 양의 반정치
행렬에 p를 쓰는 걸 더 좋아하거든요. 참고로 이건 사영 측정에 대한 표현의 일반화인데, 사영 행렬은 항상 양의
반정치이고, 실제로 고유값이
0과 1만 가능한 양의 반정치 행렬로 대안적으로 정의될 수도 있어요. 이 정의가
결과 확률에 대해 항상 확률 벡터를 얻는다는 점에서 의미가 있다는 걸 확인할 수 있어요.
첫째로, 결과 확률이라고 부르는 이 숫자들은 항상 음이 아닌 실수예요. 그건
PA와 ρ 모두 양의 반정치이고, 두 양의 반정치 행렬의 곱의 트레이스는
항상 음이 아닌 실수이기 때문이에요. 왜 그런지는 직접 생각해보세요.
둘째로, 이 숫자들의 합이 1이어야 해요. 트레이스가 선형이기 때문에,
p0부터 pN-1까지의 행렬들의 합이 항등 행렬이어야 하고, 밀도 행렬의 트레이스는 1이에요.
따라서 어떤 밀도 행렬 ρ에서 시작하더라도, 결과 확률들은 항상 확률 벡터를 이뤄요.
이제 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 사영 측정이 일반적인 측정의 특수한 경우라는 건 이미 말했는데,
사영이 항상 양의 반정치이기 때문이에요. 하지만 간단한 것부터 시작하는 게 좋으니까, qubit의 표준 기저 측정부터 시작해볼게요.
qubit의 표준 기저 측정은 두 행렬 p0와 p1로 표현할 수 있는데,
화면에 표시된 것처럼 정의돼요. p0는 |0⟩⟨0|이고, p1은 |1⟩⟨1|이에요. 둘 다 양의 반정치 행렬이고 사실 사영이기도 해서 분명히 합이 항등 행렬이 돼요.
그래서 함께 측정을 표현해요. 이 측정을 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태의 qubit에 적용하면,
결과 0이 나타날 확률은 p0 × ρ의 트레이스예요.
그리고 결과 1이 나타날 확률은 p1 × ρ의 트레이스예요. 트레이스의 순환 성질에 의해
예상대로 ρ의 두 대각 원소를 얻게 돼요. 또 다른 예시인데,
이번엔 행렬들이 사영이 아니에요. 하지만 양의 반정치이고, 밀도
행렬이기도 해요. 하지만 그건 중요하지 않고, 중요한 건 합이 항등 행렬이 된다는 거예요. 그래서 함께
측정을 표현해요. 이 측정이 플러스 상태의 qubit에 수행될 때 어떻게 되는지 볼 수 있어요. 예를 들어
어떤 한 상태에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 보기 위해서요. 확률의 계산은 화면에
표시돼 있어요. 특히, 플러스 상태가 순수 상태이고 양자 상태 벡터 |+⟩로 표현할 수 있지만,
확률을 얻으려면 그 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현인 |+⟩⟨+|를 공식에 대입해야 한다는 점을 주목해요.
그리고 파괴적 측정에 대해 이야기하고 있기 때문에, 이 qubit의 측정 후 양자 상태에 대한
명세가 없다는 점도 알아두세요. 그래서 결과
확률의 명세만 있어요. 지금으로선 마지막 예시인데, 꽤 흥미로운 거예요. 또 다시 단일
qubit의 측정이고, 이를 표현하기 위해 사면체
상태라고 알려진 네 가지 양자 상태 벡터를 정의하는 것부터 시작할게요.
이것들이 사면체 상태라고 불리는 이유는 블로흐 구에 내접하는
정사면체의 네 꼭짓점에 해당하기 때문이에요. 정사면체라고 할 때는
각 면이 정삼각형인 사면체를 의미해요. 완벽한 대칭이 있어서, 모든
변의 길이가 같고 어떤 두 인접한 변 사이에 형성되는 각도도 같아요.
이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 네 가지 가능한 결과를 가진 흥미로운 측정을 정의할 수 있어요. 말로 하면,
이 상태들의 밀도 행렬 표현을 2로 나눈 것을 행렬로 사용할 수 있어요. 이건 분명히 양의
반정치 행렬이에요. 밀도 행렬을 2로 나눈 것이니까요. 합이 실제로 항등 행렬이 되는지 확인하는 계산을 직접 해볼 수도 있지만,
다른 방법으로는 대칭성을 생각해볼 수 있어요. 이 네 상태를 평균하면
블로흐 구의 중심에 있는 완전 혼합 상태를 얻게 돼요. 하지만 네 개가 아닌
두 개로 나누기 때문에 완전 혼합 상태의 두 배, 즉 항등 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 이 측정에 대해서는
지금은 더 말하지 않을게요. 사영 측정이 아니지만 좋은 예시라는 점만 관찰하고,
이 강의 후반부에서 다시 등장할 거예요. 일반적인 측정을 표현하는 또 다른 방법은 채널로서인데, 이제
살펴볼게요. 여기서 아이디어는 고전적인 확률 상태는 대각 밀도 행렬로 표현될 수 있다는 거예요.
측정 결과는 고전적이기 때문에, 측정을 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬인 채널로 생각할 수 있어요.
측정 결과를 설명하는 행렬이요. 그럼 이걸 조금 더 자세히 살펴볼게요. 일반적인 측정에 대해
추상적으로 생각한다면, 그 측정을 채널 Φ로 표현할 수 있어요. 채널의 입력 시스템은
측정되는 시스템 X이고, 출력 시스템은 시스템 Y인데, Y의 고전적인 상태들이 측정 결과에 해당해요.
어떤 양의 정수 M에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 측정 결과로 보는 거죠.
그리고 측정 결과는 고전적이기 때문에, 시스템 X에 대한 모든 입력 밀도 행렬 ρ에 대해
출력 Φ(ρ)가 대각 밀도 행렬이어야 해요. 예를 들어 qubit의 표준 기저 측정에 대해 생각하고,
그 측정이 채널로 표현된다고 생각하면, 화면에 있는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
입력 밀도 행렬이 ρ라면, ⟨0|ρ|0⟩의 확률로 결과 0을 얻게 되고,
⟨1|ρ|1⟩의 확률로 결과 1을 얻게 돼요. 이 고전적인
측정 결과들을 밀도 행렬로 표현하면 해당하는 채널에 대한 이 식을 얻게 되는데,
이게 바로 완전 위상 감쇠 채널이에요. 이는 완전 위상 감쇠
채널이 극단적인 형태의 디코히런스를 나타낸다는 생각과 일치해요. 디코히런스는 여러 의미일 수 있지만, 제가 이 용어를 쓸 때는
양자 상태가 고전적으로 되려는 경향을 말하는 거예요. 우리가 다루는 시스템 주변의 환경이
어떤 의미에서 관찰하고 있기 때문인데, 다시 말해 측정하고 있는 거죠.
그래서 측정 결과는 방금 설명했던 것처럼 채널로 표현될 수 있어요. 하지만 이건 단순한 가능성이 아니라
일반적인 측정의 특성화예요. 제가 말하려는 건 이런 거예요. 물론 측정을 나타내지 않는
채널들도 있어요. 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이 아닐 수 있거든요. 하지만 어떤 입력 상태 ρ를 선택하든
채널의 출력이 항상 대각 밀도 행렬이라면, 그 채널을 반드시 화면에 표시된 형태로,
즉 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치 행렬들의 모음인 어떤 측정에 대해
표현할 수 있어요. 이게 여러 이유로 좋은데, 그중 하나가 측정을 행렬들의 모음으로 정의하는 방식이
아무것도 빠뜨리지 않는다는 걸 기본적으로 알려준다는 거예요.
다르게 말하면, 측정을 채널로 생각하는 이 방식은 운용적이거나
공리적이에요. 측정이 무엇이어야 하는지, 즉 양자 정보를 고전적인 정보로 변환하는 물리적 과정을 포착한다는 의미에서요.
그리고 이게 순수하게 대수적인 첫 번째 측정 표현과 완전히 동등한 것으로 밝혀졌어요.
이 동등성의 증명은 이 영상에서 다루지 않을 거예요. 하지만
어렵지는 않고, 관심 있다면 영상 설명에 링크된 강의 자료에서 증명을 찾을 수 있어요.
주어진 상태의 시스템에 일반적인 측정이 수행될 때 어떻게 되는지 다뤘는데,
적어도 파괴적 측정의 경우에 대해서는요. 다음으로 부분 측정에 대해 다룰 거예요. 복합 시스템의
일부만 측정된다는 의미예요. 정확히 말하면, 밀도 행렬 ρ로 표현된 상태에 함께 있는 시스템 쌍 XZ가 있다고 하고,
합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치 행렬들의 모음으로 표현된 측정이
시스템 X에만 수행된다고 해요. 자연스럽게 이 결과는 측정 결과이고,
파괴적 측정에 대해 이야기하고 있으니 측정 과정이 시스템
X를 파괴한다고 상상할 수 있어요. 하지만 여전히 시스템 Z가 남아 있고, X의 측정이 Z의
상태에 어떤 영향을 미치는지 이해해야 해요. 먼저 결과
확률에 대해 얘기해볼게요. 시스템 X만 측정하고 있으니까, 다양한 결과들이 나타날 확률은
X만의 상태에만 의존할 수 있어요. 즉 X의 축소 상태에만 의존할 수 있다는 거예요.
특히 어떤 주어진 결과 a가 나타날 확률은
이전과 같은 공식으로 주어져요. 즉 PA와 X의 축소 상태 ρ_X의 곱의 트레이스예요.
상태 ρ_X는 ρ에서 Z를 추적(trace out)해서 얻어요. 그래서 이를 대입할 수 있고,
바로 명확하지는 않지만, 얻은 식은 화면에 표시된 것처럼 대안적으로 쓸 수 있어요.
시스템 Z 위의 항등 행렬과 PA의 텐서 곱에
ρ를 곱한 것의 트레이스예요. 이건 확인해볼 가치가 있는 등식이에요. Z에는 아무것도 하지 않으니까
이런 식으로 Z 위의 항등 행렬이 나타나는 게 직관적으로 맞아요. 하지만
대수적으로도 확인할 수 있어요. 먼저 ρ가 두 행렬의 텐서 곱인 경우를 고려하고, 그 다음
선형성을 이용해서 모든 ρ에 대해 성립해야 함을 결론짓는 것을 추천해요. 그리고 PA가
양의 반정치라거나 ρ가 밀도 행렬이라는 사실에 의존하지 않는다는 점도 말해두고 싶어요. 이건
PA와 ρ 자리에 어떤 행렬을 놓더라도 성립하는 등식이에요. 식이 의미가 있는 올바른 차원을 가지기만 한다면요.
이제 Z의 상태가 측정에 의해 어떻게 영향 받는지 살펴볼게요. 자연스러운 접근 방식은
제 관점에서 측정을 채널로 생각하는 거예요. 여기 우리 측정과 연관시키는 채널이 있고,
이걸 시스템 X에서 고전적인 상태들이 측정 결과에 해당하는 새로운 시스템 Y로의 채널로 생각하고 있어요. 그래서 이 공식에서
σ는 시스템 X만의 상태를 나타내요. 쌍 XZ가 상태 ρ에 있는 동안
이 채널을 시스템 X에 적용하면, 여기 있는 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요.
다시, 이걸 확인하는 데 필요한 만큼 시간을 가져요. 다시 한번, 먼저 ρ가 두 행렬의 텐서 곱인 경우를 고려하고
그 다음 선형성을 이용하는 것을 추천해요. 이제 첫 번째 시스템이 고전적이고
두 번째 시스템이 양자인 이 유형의 상태를 밀도 행렬
강의에서 예시로 본 적이 있어요. 각 a는 어떤 확률로 발생하는데, 그게 두 번째 텐서 인수의 트레이스예요. 그래서
이 두 번째 텐서 인수들을 확률을 곱한 밀도 행렬로 생각할 수 있어요. 따라서 특정 측정 결과 a를 얻었을 때
Z의 상태를 구하려면, 그냥 확률로 나누면 돼요. 다시 말해
두 번째 텐서 인수를 자기 자신의 트레이스로 나눠서 정규화하면 돼요. 요약하면, 쌍 XZ가 상태 ρ에 있는 동안
X에 대한 측정을 수행하면 이런 일이 일어나요. 첫째로, 각 결과 a는
항등 행렬과 PA의 텐서 곱에 ρ를 곱한 것의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요. 둘째로, 결과
a를 얻었을 때 Z의 상태는 화면에 표시된 식으로 주어져요. 이건 조금 전에 봤던
행렬을 정규화해서 얻은 것이고, 그 행렬을 a가 나타날 확률로 나누는 것과 같아요.
이건 확률이 0이 아닐 때만 의미가 있다는 점을 말해야겠어요. 그렇지 않으면 0으로 나누게 되니까요.
하지만 괜찮아요. 일어나지 않는 일들에 대해서는 신경 쓸 필요가 없거든요. 이
강의 부분에서는 Neymark 정리라고 알려진 측정에 관한 간단하지만 근본적인 정리를 다룰 거예요.
요약하면, 어떤 측정이든 화면의 그림이 제시하는 방식으로 구현될 수 있다는 거예요.
말로 표현하면, 시스템 X에 대한 주어진 일반적인 측정은 다음과 같이 구현될 수 있어요.
먼저 고전적인 상태들이 가능한 측정 결과들인 초기화된 작업 공간 시스템 Y를 도입해요. 측정 결과는 0부터 n-1까지 번호가 매겨져 있다고 가정하고요.
그 다음 쌍 YX에 유니터리 연산 U를 수행하고,
그 다음 Y에 표준 기저 측정을 수행해요. 그러면 기본적으로 모든 것이
결정돼요. U의 선택만 빼고요. 그리고 정리가 말하는 건 이 유니터리
연산 U를 다양한 결과의 확률이 항상 주어진 일반적인 측정과
일치하도록 선택하는 것이 실제로 가능하다는 거예요. 이제 Neymark 정리가 어떻게 증명되는지 살펴볼게요. 어렵지 않아요. 그냥
유니터리 연산 U에 대한 좋은 선택을 하고 그게 맞는지 확인하면 되거든요. 하지만 먼저 행렬 이론의
기본적인 사실이 필요해요. 어떤 양의 반정치 행렬 P에 대해서도 Q 제곱이 P와 같은
유일한 양의 반정치 행렬 Q가 항상 존재한다는 거예요. 일반적으로 제곱해서 P를 주는 행렬이 많을 수 있지만,
그중 양의 반정치인 것은 항상 딱 하나예요. 이 행렬을 나타내는 표기법은 P의 제곱근이고,
말로도 그렇게 불러요. 어떤 양의 반정치 행렬 P의 제곱근을 계산하고 싶다면,
P의 스펙트럼 분해를 먼저 계산하고 그 다음
각 고유값을 그 제곱근으로 바꾸면서 고유 벡터들은 그대로 두면 돼요. 고유값들은 모두 음이
아니니까 이게 의미가 있고, 얻는 행렬이 실제로 양의 반정치이고
P의 제곱이 된다는 걸 쉽게 알 수 있어요. 유일성은 다른 문제인데, 행렬에 대한 기본적인 사실들을 이용해서
증명하는 건 어렵지 않지만 이 강의에서 다소 벗어나는 내용이라 그 부분은
주어진 것으로 받아들이고 넘어갈게요. 이제 그 개념을 이해했으니, 작동하는 유니터리 연산 U를
쉽게 명시할 수 있어요. 화면에 표시된 패턴과 일치하는 어떤 유니터리 행렬이든 실제로
작동할 거예요. 처음 n개의 열은, X가 이전처럼 n개의 고전적인 상태를 가진다고 가정하면, 측정을 표현하는
행렬들의 제곱근을 서로 쌓아서 얻어요. 나머지 열들은 무엇이든 상관없어요.
전체 행렬이 유니터리인 한 어떻게 해도 달라지는 게 없어요.
참고로, 채널의 Kraus 표현과 Stein spring 표현 사이의 연결과 닮았다는 걸 눈치챘다면, 그건 우연이 아니에요.
실제로 여기 있는 건 그것의 특수한 경우인데, 우리의 Kraus 행렬들이 모두 양의
반정치라는 거예요. 확인해야 할 두 가지가 있어요. 첫 번째는 이 U의 선택이 실제로 작동하는지이고,
두 번째는 명시되지 않은 열들을 U가 유니터리가 되도록 선택할 수 있는지예요. 첫 번째부터 시작할게요.
시작하는 상태는 이래요. 아래 시스템 Y는 영 상태로 초기화되어 있고, 위쪽 시스템은
상태 ρ에서 시작해요. 그 다음 U를 수행하는데, U로 켤레를 취하는 거예요.
이걸 모두 블록 행렬로 표현할 수 있어요. 화면에 표시된 것처럼요. 왼쪽에 U, 오른쪽에 U 대거,
중간에 |0⟩⟨0|과 ρ의 텐서 곱이 있는데, 여기 있는 형태를 취해요. 왼쪽 위 모서리에 ρ가 있고
나머지는 모두 0이에요. 이 곱에 대해 잠시 생각해보면, U의 명시되지 않은 항목들이
전혀 중요하지 않다는 게 분명해요. 중간 행렬의 0 항목들에 항상 곱해지니까요.
그리고 곱셈을 진행하면 여기에 표시된
행렬을 블록 행렬로 얻게 돼요. 아니면 직접 표기법을 사용해서
이렇게 표현할 수도 있어요. 실제로 이 형태가 우리에게 더 편리하니까, 이
식에 집중해볼게요. 편의를 위해 이 행렬, 즉 밀도 행렬에
σ라는 이름을 붙일게요. 마지막 단계는 Y에 대한 표준 기저 측정이에요. 그러면 Y의 축소 상태를 계산해볼게요.
우리가 가진 식을 이용하면 쉬워요. 그냥 두 번째 텐서 인수에 해당하는 X를 추적(trace out)하면 되거든요.
그러면 어떤 주어진 결과 a가 나타날 확률은 a에 해당하는 대각 항목이에요.
이렇게 쓸 수 있고, PA의 제곱근 × ρ × PA의 제곱근의 트레이스와 같아요.
그리고 트레이스의 순환 성질에 의해 PA × ρ의 트레이스를 얻게 되는데,
이게 우리가 원했던 거예요. 그래서 다양한 결과들이 나타날 확률이 올바르고, 항상 처음에 시작했던
원래 측정과 일치해요. 확인해야 할 두 번째 것은
U의 명시되지 않은 열들을 U가 유니터리가 되도록 채워넣는 게 가능한지예요.
이건 측정을 표현하는 행렬들의 제곱근으로 이루어진 처음 n개의 열이 정규직교라는 사실로부터 따라와요.
이건 꽤 직접적으로 확인할 수 있어요. 관련 세부 사항은 화면에 있어요.
원한다면 잠시 영상을 멈추고 생각해보세요. 하지만 이전에 제안했던 것처럼,
이건 사실 이전 강의에서 접했던 것의 특수한 경우예요.
이게 지금까지의 증명이에요. 이 강의에서는 파괴적 측정에 집중했어요. 측정된 시스템의 측정 후
양자 상태에 대한 명세가 없다는 의미에서요. 반면 비파괴적 측정은
고전적인 측정 결과뿐만 아니라 측정된 시스템의 측정 후 양자 상태도 있어요.
앞으로 보게 되듯이 Neymark 정리와 자연스러운 연결이 있어요. 사실 비파괴적
측정을 수학적으로 공식화하는 방법이 여러 가지 있는데, Neymark 정리에서 직접 나오는
한 가지 공식화부터 시작할게요. 합이 항등 행렬이 되는 양의 반정치
행렬들의 모음으로 표현된 일반적인 측정, 즉 파괴적 측정을 고려해요. p0부터 pN-1까지요. 그러면 이걸
Neymark 정리의 맥락에서 다뤘던 이 측정의 구현을 고려해서 비파괴적 측정으로 바꿀 수 있어요.
새로운 시스템 Y를 도입하고, 유니터리 연산 U를 통해 X와 상호작용시킨 다음, Y에 표준
기저 측정을 수행해요. 그러면 시스템 X가 여전히 남아 있고, 그 상태를 고려할 수 있어요.
앞서 한 분석을 바탕으로, 특정 측정 결과 a를 얻었을 때 X의 측정 후 상태가
이렇게 생긴 밀도 행렬로 주어진다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
말로 하면, 해당 측정 행렬의 제곱근으로 켤레를 취하고 그 다음
정규화해요. 비파괴적 측정을 공식화하는 또 다른 방법은 더 일반적인 건데, 채널의 Kraus
행렬로 표현하는 거예요. 이게 Nielsen과 Chuang의 유명한 교과서에서 찾을 수 있는 측정의 정의예요.
예를 들어, M0부터 Mm-1까지가 화면에 표시된 방정식을 만족하는 정사각 행렬들이라고 해요.
즉 이 행렬들을 채널을 표현하는 Kraus 행렬로 생각할 수 있다는 거예요.
실제로 이 행렬들은 채널을 표현하지만, 비파괴적 측정도 표현해요.
주어진 상태 ρ의 시스템이 측정될 때 어떻게 작동하는지는, 먼저 결과 확률이
화면에 표시된 방정식으로 주어져요. 각 결과는 Ma × ρ × Ma 대거의 트레이스와 같은 확률로 나타나요.
그리고 결과 a가 나타났을 때, 측정된 시스템의 상태는 이렇게 돼요.
이런 종류의 비파괴적 측정은 Neymark 정리에서 했던 것과 비슷하게 구현될 수 있어요.
원한다면 직접 생각해보세요. 비파괴적 측정의 개념을 이것보다 더 일반화하는 것도 가능해요.
예를 들어, 양자 기계라고 불리는 개념이 때로 꽤 유용하지만, 이 영상에서는 다루지
않을 거예요. 강의 마지막 부분에서는 측정과 관련된 두 가지 과제에 대해 간략하게 다룰 거예요. 양자 상태 판별과 양자 상태
단층 촬영이에요. 두 개념 모두에 대해 할 말이 꽤 많은데, 정말 표면적인 부분만 다룰 거예요.
그러면 이 용어들이 무엇을 의미하고 어떻게 다른지 명확히 해보는 것부터 시작할게요.
첫 번째는 양자 상태 판별이에요. 여기서 아이디어는 어떤 시스템의 알려진 양자 상태들의 모음과
이 상태들과 관련된 확률들을 가지고 있다는 거예요.
정확히 말하면, ρ0부터 ρM-1까지가 시스템 X의 가능한 양자 상태들을 나타내는 밀도 행렬들이고,
p0부터 pN-1까지가 이 상태들과 관련된 확률들이라고 해요. 확률들을 하나의
벡터로 모으면 확률 벡터를 얻어요. 이걸 간단히 말하면 양자
상태들의 앙상블을 가지고 있다는 거예요. 이제 양자 상태 판별을 과제 또는 문제로 추상적으로 생각해볼 수 있어요.
먼저 0과 N-1 사이의 숫자가 확률에 따라 무작위로 선택돼요. 그 다음 시스템 X가
무작위로 선택된 숫자에 해당하는 상태로 준비돼요. 목표는 X를 측정해서
어떤 숫자가 선택되었는지 알아내는 거예요.
그래서 사전 확률과 함께 유한한 수의 대안이 있고, 목표는 실제로 어떤 대안이 발생했는지 알아내는 거예요.
일부 상태와 확률 선택에 대해서는 이게 쉬울 수 있고, 다른 경우에는 오류 가능성 없이 하는 게 불가능할 수 있어요.
그리고 물어볼 수 있는 다양한 구체적인 질문들이 있어요. 예를 들면 오류를 낼 최소 확률은 뭔지,
이 최소 오류 확률을 달성하는 측정은 어떻게 생겼는지 같은 거예요.
반면 양자 상태 단층 촬영은 달라요. 여기서는 시스템의 알려지지 않은 양자 상태를 가지고 있어요.
그래서 보통 사전 확률이나 가능한 대안에 대한 어떤 정보도 없어요.
하지만 이번엔 상태의 단 하나의 사본이 아니라 많은 독립적인 사본들이 주어져요.
즉 어떤 큰 수 n에 대해 각각 독립적으로 상태 ρ로 준비된
n개의 동일한 시스템 X1부터 Xn까지가 있다는 거예요. 이번의 목표는 시스템들을 측정해서
이 알려지지 않은 양자 상태의 근사치를 밀도 행렬로 찾는 거예요.
요약하면, 양자 상태 판별에서는 상태의 단 하나의 사본을 가지고
유한한 수의 알려진 대안들 중에서 판별하려 해요. 양자 상태 단층 촬영에서는 알려지지 않은 양자 상태의 많은 독립적인
사본들을 가지고 있고, 목표는 그 상태에 대한 설명이나 적어도 괜찮은 근사치를 찾는 거예요.
양자 상태 판별은 흥미로운데, 계산이나 암호학 같은 분야에서 흔히 나타나는 상황 유형을 추상화하기 때문이에요.
유한한 가능성 집합 중 하나의 대안이 발생했고, 우리나 다른 누군가가 양자 시스템을 측정해서 어떤 게 발생했는지 알아내려 하는 경우에요.
가장 단순한 비자명한 경우는 딱 두 가지 대안이 있는 경우인데, M이 2와 같아요. 그러면 과제는 한 쌍의
상태들 사이에서 판별하는 거예요. 이 경우는 본질적으로 완전히 해결된 문제예요. 목표가 잘못된 판별 확률을 최소화하는 것이라면요.
측정에 대한 최적의 선택이 있는데, 종종
Helstrom 측정이라고 불려요. 사실 사영 측정이고,
다음과 같이 표현할 수 있어요. 먼저 두 대안 사이의 가중 차이를 고려해요.
즉 p0 × ρ0 빼기 p1 × ρ1이에요. 두 상태 각각을 뽑을 확률을 상태 자체에 곱하고
차를 구하는 거예요. 이건 자기 켤레 전치와 같으니까 에르미트 행렬이에요.
그래서 스펙트럼 분해가 있고, 고유값이 모두 실수라는 걸 알 수 있어요. 그러면 화면에 표시된
형태로 쓰인 스펙트럼 분해가 있다고 가정할게요. 다음에 할 일은
고유값들을 두 집합으로 모으는 거예요. 모든 양의 고유값은 한 집합에, 모든 음의 고유값은
다른 집합에 넣어요. 정확히 말하면, S0을 해당 고유값 λk가
음이 아닌 모든 인덱스 k의 집합으로 하고, S1은 나머지 인덱스들, 즉 음의 고유값에 해당하는 것들로 해요.
여기서 0인 고유값들에 해당하는 인덱스들을 어느 집합에 넣는지는 실제로 중요하지 않아요.
여기서는 임의로 0인 것들을 S0에 포함시키지만, 일부 또는 전부가 S1에 포함되어도 아무 차이가 없어요.
정말 중요한 건 양의 고유값과 음의 고유값을 분리한다는 거예요. 마지막으로 두 사영 Pi
0과 Pi 1을 화면에 표시된 것처럼 정의해요. 말로 하면, Pi 0은
양의 고유값과 영인 고유값에 해당하는 고유 벡터들로 이루어진 부분 공간으로의 사영이에요.
음이 아닌 고유값들에 해당하는 고유 벡터들이 펼치는 부분 공간으로의 사영이고, Pi 1은
음의 고유값들에 해당하는 고유 벡터들이 펼치는 공간으로의 사영이에요. 이것들은 실제로 사영이고,
더하면 항등 행렬이 돼요. 왜냐하면 고유 벡터들 S0부터 SN-1까지가 정규직교 기저를 이루기 때문이에요.
지금 다루는 상황, 즉 측정되는 상태가 확률 p0로 ρ0이고 확률 p1로 ρ1인 경우에 이 측정이 수행되면,
올바른 식별 확률이 고유값 λ0부터 λN-1까지로 꽤 단순한 공식을 가진다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
계산의 세부 사항은 이 영상에서 다루지 않을 거예요. 관심 있다면 영상 설명에 링크된 자료를 참고하거나,
이 공식이 실제로 맞는지 스스로 확인해보세요. 이 확률을
일반적으로 트레이스 노름이라고 불리는 행렬 노름을 사용해서 표현할 수도 있어요. 벡터의 유클리드 노름과 표기법이 비슷한데,
트레이스 노름임을 나타내기 위해 아래첨자로 1이 있어요. 트레이스 노름은 매우 중요하고
양자 컴퓨팅에서 매우 자주 나와요. 하지만 이 강의에서는 더 많이 다루지 않을 거예요.
에르미트 행렬에 대해 정의하는 한 가지 방법은 고유값들의 절댓값의 합이라는 거예요.
그래서 두 번째 등식을 그 정의에서 직접 따라오는 것으로 생각할 수 있어요.
트레이스 노름은 더 일반적인 다른 방법으로도 정의될 수 있는데, 다음 강의에서 다시 만나게 될 거예요.
사실 이게 할 수 있는 최선이에요. 이 측정은 최적이에요. 올바른 추측 확률을 최대화하는 것이 목표라면요.
그 사실은 때로 Helstrom-Holevo 정리라고 불리고, 때로 그냥 Helstrom
정리라고도 불려요. 그래서 올바름 확률 측면에서 이 측정을 능가할 수 없어요.
좋은 점은 측정 자체에 대한 간단한 레시피가 있고, 트레이스
노름으로 표현된 올바름 확률에 대한 정확한 공식이 있다는 거예요.
트레이스 노름은 바로 이 이유로 밀도 행렬들 사이의 관측 가능한 차이를 측정하는 방법으로 자주 사용돼요.
그리고 사람들이 상태 사이의 트레이스 거리를 언급할 때, 보통 두 밀도 행렬의 차이의 트레이스 노름의
2분의 1을 가리키는데, 여기서 p0와 p1이 모두 1/2인 경우에 해당해요.
그게 고려하기에 자연스러운 경우예요. 두 상태에 대한 양자 상태 판별은 Helstrom 측정으로
최적으로 해결되는데, 간단한 레시피와 올바름 확률에 대한 간단한 공식이 있어요.
그러면 세 개 이상의 상태를 판별하고 싶을 때는 어떻게 될까요? 이 경우에는 측정의 최적 선택에 대한 일반적인
공식이나 최대 올바름 확률에 대한 간단한 식이 없어요.
하지만 컴퓨터의 도움으로 최적 측정의 좋은 근사치를 찾는 건 가능해요.
특히 반정치 프로그래밍이라고 알려진 정말 매력적이고 강력한 최적화 기법을 사용해서 할 수 있어요.
하지만 예를 들어 연필과 종이로 실현 가능하게 구현할 수 있는 건 아니에요. 반면 누군가가
어떤 측정에 대한 설명을 주고 그 측정이 양자 상태 판별 과제에 최적이라고 주장한다면,
그 주장을 검증하거나 반증하는 건 사실 매우 쉬워요. 이른바 Holevo-Yuen-
Kennedy-Lax 조건을 사용하면 돼요. 이 영상에서 그게 뭔지 설명하지는 않을 거예요. 하지만 간단한 조건들이고, 이게
가능하다는 게 꽤 멋진 거예요. 여기 강의 앞부분에서 봤던 사면체 상태로
돌아가는 예시가 있어요. 네 상태 중 하나를 각각 4분의 1의 확률로 무작위로 받는다고 해요.
목표는 어떤 상태를 받았는지 알아내는 거예요. 놀랍지 않겠지만,
이걸 하기 위해 측정에서 할 수 있는 최선은 사면체 측정이에요. 임의의 순수 상태 모음에 대해 항상
이런 걸 할 수 있는 건 아니지만, 여기서는 관련된 대칭성 덕분에 가능해요.
실제로 유효한 측정을 얻게 되고, 조금 전에 언급한 Holevo-Yuen-Kennedy-Lax 조건을 통해
이게 실제로 최적 측정임을 증명하는 게 꽤 간단해요. 구체적으로 여기서 일어나는 건
측정이 항상 1/2 확률로 맞는다는 거예요. 대안이 네 가지이니까 나쁜 게 아니에요.
올바른 추측 확률이 무작위 추측보다 두 배 좋고, 이 상태들에 대해 할 수 있는 최선이에요.
이제 양자 상태 단층 촬영에 대해 조금 더 말할게요.
알려지지 않은 양자 상태의 많은 독립적인 사본들이 있고, 그 상태를 표현하는 밀도 행렬의 근사치를 찾는 게 목표예요.
사실 이 문제에는 가정과 특히 어떤 종류의 측정을 허용하는지에 따라 달라지는 여러 다른 변형들이 있어요.
예를 들어 각 시스템을 개별적으로 측정하고 결과들을 어떻게든 결합해서 밀도 행렬에 대한 설명을 얻을 수도 있고,
아니면 모든 시스템을 하나의 복합 시스템으로 함께 측정할 수도 있는데, 이론적으로는 훨씬 더 좋지만
기술적인 관점에서는 훨씬 더 까다롭기도 해요. 측정에 대한 선택 외에도,
중요한 고려 사항이 있는데, 측정에서 얻은 데이터로부터 밀도 행렬에 대한 설명을 어떻게
재구성하는지예요. 세부 사항은 다루지 않을 거예요. 제 요점은 단순히
양자 상태 단층 촬영이 단일 절차가 아니라 많은 다양한 변형을 가진 포괄적인 개념에 가깝다는 걸
시사하는 거예요. 이 문제에 대한 많은 연구가 있었는데, 비교적
최근의 획기적인 결과들도 있어요. 사본 수 n과 얻을 수 있는 근사의 정확도를 연결하는 결과들이고,
계속해서 흥미롭고 활발한 연구 분야예요. 강의를 마무리하면서, qubit의
양자 상태 단층 촬영과 그 방법을 살펴볼게요. ρ가 단일 qubit의 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬이고,
X1부터 Xn까지가 모두 독립적으로 상태 ρ로 준비된 qubit들이라고 해요.
이 논의를 위해 n이 크다고 가정할게요. 할 수 있는 건 시스템들을 세 개의 대략 같은 크기의 더미로 나누는 거예요.
첫 번째 더미에서는 플러스-마이너스 기저에 대한 측정을 수행할 거예요.
플러스에 해당하는 각 결과에 대해 +1을 기록하고, 마이너스에
해당하는 각 결과에 대해 -1을 기록할 거예요. 이 측정을 더 간결하게 설명하는 방법은
파울리 X 측정이라고 하는 거예요. 플러스와 마이너스 상태가 파울리 X 행렬의 고유 벡터이고
해당 고유값이 +1과 -1이기 때문이에요. 사실 그게 훨씬 더 일반적인 표현 방식이고,
해당 고유값은 +1과 -1이에요. 사실 그게 훨씬 더 일반적인 설명 방식이에요. 그리고
실제로 점수의 기댓값은 Σx × ρ의 트레이스와 같아요. 이 기댓값이 무엇인지 반드시 알 수는 없지만,
많은 시도에 걸쳐 점수를 평균하면 큰 수의 법칙에 의해 이 기댓값의
괜찮은 근사치를 얻을 가능성이 꽤 높아요. 그리고 그 말을 더 정량적으로 표현하려면 활용할 수 있는 잘 알려진 통계적 범위들이 있어요.
두 번째 3분의 1의 시스템들에 대해서는 Σy로 비슷한 작업을 해요.
여기서 바뀌는 건 Σy의 고유 벡터인 +i와 -i 상태를 사용한다는 것뿐이에요.
마찬가지로 Σz에 대해서도 하는데, 이 경우 표준 기저 벡터가 고유 벡터예요.
그런 다음 마지막으로 화면에 표시된 공식을 사용할 수 있어요. ρ가 파울리 행렬들의 선형 결합으로 쓰였을 때
계수들이 어떻게 되어야 하는지 알려주는 공식이에요. 이 계수들에 대한 근사치를 대입하고
양의 반정치 행렬을 얻기 위해 약간 조정해서
ρ의 근사치를 얻게 돼요. 물론 근사의 정확도나
얼마나 신뢰할 수 있는지 같은 세부 사항은 다루지 않았지만, qubit에 단층 촬영을 수행하는 한 가지 방법의 기본적인 아이디어는 전달됐으면 해요.
사면체 측정을 사용해서 qubit 단층 촬영을 하는 것도 가능해요. 그리고 사실 이게
적어도 수학적인 관점에서는 꽤 간단하고 우아해요. 할 수 있는 건 알려지지 않은 양자 상태의
모든 독립적인 사본들에 이 측정 하나만 수행하는 거예요. 그리고
여기 표시된 놀라운 공식을 사용하면, 해당 측정 결과가 나타나는 빈도의 비율로 각 k에 대해
Pk × ρ의 트레이스를 추정해서 상태의 근사치를 구할 수 있어요. 다시 말하지만, 이건 네 상태 사이의 완벽한 대칭 덕분에 작동해요.
그리고 사실 더 큰 시스템으로의 이 접근 방식의 일반화와 관련된 정말 매력적이고 미해결된 문제들이 있어요.
여기서 강의를 마치면 딱 좋을 것 같아요. 시청해 주셔서 감사해요.
다음 강의에서도 함께해 주셨으면 해요. 다음 강의는 정화와 충실도에 관한 거예요. 그럼 또 봐요!